بفي خان يونس الدكتور ناهض ابو طعيمه مدير
المستشفى مستشفى الجراحه
بمجمع ناصر الصحي في خانيونس اهلا بك
دكتور ناهض نتوقف مع ما قاله الكتور اشرف
القدره من ان الاوضاع الصحيه في خانيونس
كارثيه ما الذي يمكن ان يضاف حول الاوضاع
الصحيه
هناك نعم الوضع كارث في مجمع الاصر الطبي
وصلنا حتى اللحظه خ
شهيدا ووصلنا اكثر من 100 اصابه قسم
الاستقبال والطوارئ الكثير من الاصابات
احتاجت الى تدخلات جراحيه والان الطواقم
الطبيه تجري العمليات الجراحيه المتنوعه
للمصابين الذين وصلوا ولكن الكثير من
الاصابات تحتاج الى تدخلات جراحيه والان
متواجده في الطوارئ يتم عمل لها اللازم و
ندخلها تباعا الى اقسام العمليات الان قسم
العمليات يعمل بطاقته القسوى ويعمل جميع
غرف العمليات في المجمع لانقاذ المصابين
والجرحى الذين وصلوا الى المجمع الاصابات
حرجه جدا اصابات في البطن والصدر
والاطراف كثير من الاصابات
اي وصلت متاخره من اماكن القصف كون
الاسعاف لم لم يصل اليها اي ساعه الحدث
ووصلت في وضع سيء جدا
وتصارع الطواقم الطبيه لانقاذ حياتهم في
هذه اللحظات نعم استقبال والطوارئ الان
ممتلئ بالاصابات التي تحتاج الى تدخلات
جراحيه وتحتاج الى مكوث في المستشفى وفي
العنايات المركزه والان الاسره في الطوارئ
كلها ممتلئه والعمليات تعمل على مدار
الساعه منذ ساعات الفجر ومنذ وصول
الاصابات الى الطوارئ نعم في مجمع ناصر
الطبي هل من من خطط طوارئ اضافيه في هذه
المرحله التي يصفها الجميع بالمرحله
الصعبه مع توسيع العمليه العسكريه في خان
يونس هل من خطط
اضافيه مجمع ناصر الطبي يعتبر مؤسسه صحيه
كبيره مؤسسه صحيه يجب ان تكون محميه من
القانون الدولي الا ان هذا الاحتلال اي لا
يضرب بعرض الحائط كل القوانين الدوليه
مجمع ناصر الطبي هي مؤسسه كبيره
وتحتوي على كثير من المرضى الذين لا
يستطيعون الخروج منها ولا يستطيعون المشي
على المشي او الخروج منها كون الاصابات
حرجه كثير منهم تعرضوا لاصابات شديده في
العمود الفقري ولا يستطيعون الحركه كثير
منهم مبتوري الاطراف سواء العلويه او
السفليه كثير منهم تعرضوا الى صابات شديده
في الدماغ وفي الصدر وهم الان مشلي او شلل
نصفي او شلل كلي لا يستطيعون الخروج من
هذه المؤسسه الكبيره ولا يوجد اي مؤسسه
خارج محافظه خان يونس تستطيع ان تستوعب
العدد الكبير من هؤلاء المصابين المبيت في
اقسام المبيد اضافه الى ذلك في مستشفى
ناصر 40 سرير عنايه مركزه الان كلها
ممتلئه بالمصابين ولا يوجد اي سرير عنايه
مركزه في اماكن اخرى لاستيعاب هؤلاء هذا
العدد الكبير من المصابين المبيت في اقصم
العنايه
المركزه نعم من واقع اليوم وتطورات
الميدانيه في مدينه خان يونس كان محيط
مستشفى او مجمع ناصر الطبي قد ترض للقصف
ايضا مستشفى الامل الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني يقول بان الدبابات الاسرائيليه
اقتربت من هل لديكم مخاوف من تكرار
سيناريو ما تعرضت له المستشفيات ومجمع
الشفاء الطبي في غزه وشمال القطاع دكتور
ناهض نعم الطواقم الطبيه والكوادر التي
تعمل في مجمع ناصر الطبي قلقون جدا ومتخوف
فون جدا من تكرار
سيناريو ما حدث في مجمع الشفاء الطبي وفي
مستشفيات المناطق الشماليه نعم هناك تخوف
كبير كون هذا
الاحتلال لا يعرف اي خطوط حمراء ولا يابه
للمجتمع الدولي ولا يابه بالقانون الدولي
الذي يحمي هذه المؤسسات
الصحيه وما حدث في الشفاء والمستشفيات
الشماليه ممكن ان يحدث في مجمع ناصر ال
طبي وخروج مستشفى ناصر عن
الخدمه هذا كارثه صحيه كبيره لا
نستطيع تقديم اي خدمه طبيه او صحيه
للمصابين هذا المجمع الكبير الذي يحتوي
الان الى اكثر من 400 مصاب كون كلهم تحت
المتابعه واغلبهم يحتاجون الى تدخلات
جراحيه لا لا نستطيع او لا نقدر اجلائهم
الى اي مكان اخر الامكانات المتوفره او
الحد الاد ربما من الامكانات التي تتوفر
لدى مجمع ناصر الطبي في ضوء شح المساعدات
ما الذي وصلكم طيله الفتره الماضيه وكيف
هو الوضع بالنسبه للمساعدات الطبيه
والصحيه الاغاثه في هذه
[موسيقى]
الاثناء بدايه ما وصلنا لا يغطي 3% من
احتياجنا الحقيقي كون العدد كبير من هذه
الاصابات اولا ثانيا ما يصل من احتياجات
ما هو نحتاجه ما يصل لنا ما هو نحتاجه
نريد ان يتم التنسيق معنا ما نحتاجه من
احتياجات من مستلزمات ومستهلكات طبيه تصل
لنا احتياجات لا نحتاجها كثير منها لا
نريدها ولا نحتاجها ولا ولا تنفعنا في هذه
الفتره الحرجه من
الحرب اصابات عديده واصابات كثيره تصل لنا
لمجمع تحتاج الى غيارات تحتاج الى عمليات
تحتاج الى تدخلات كثيره ويوجد نقص حااد في
هذه المستلزمات والمستهلكات الضروريه التي
نحتاجها لتقديم الخدمه
للمصابين وخاصه خاصه
اي اجهزه تثبيت كسور العظام الخارجيه
ادويه العمليات ادويه العنايه المركزه
وكثير منها نحتاجها ولكن يوجد نقص حاد
فيها في في الاونه الاخيره كون الاصابات
التي تصلنا اصابات كثيره في العظام وتحتاج
الى تثبيت للكسور وتحتاج الى تدخلات
وتحتاج الى دخول في اقسام العنايات
المركزه و نستهلك كثير من الادويه
والمستلزمات في اقسام العمليات والعنايات
المركزه لهؤلاء المصابين بالتالي ما هي
رسالتكم في هذا التوقيت
الصعب رسالتنا هو حمايه المؤسسه الصحيه من
الانهيار حمايه مجمع ناصر
الطبي حمايه مجمع ناصر الطبي
حمايه مجمع ناصر الطبي من الاستهداف حمايه
الكوادر الطبيه من
الاستهداف لنستطيع تقديم لنستطيع تقديم
خدمه طبيه لمرضانا
ومصابي ماذا عن اوضاع النازحين ممن يعني
نزحوا الى المستشفيات ويرابط
فيها ويحاولون الاحتماء بالمستشفيات يعني
كل المستشفيات كانت مركز لايواء النازحين
الذين قدموا من مناطق مختلفه بدايه من
شمال القطاع الى مستشفياته ومن ثم نزحوا
الى جنوبه وايضا الى مستشفياته بالتاكيد
مجمع ناصر الطبي هناك الكثير من النازحين
في كيف تبدو اوضاعهم
دكتور نعم مازال هناك عدد كبير من
النازحين داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي وفي ساحاته
وفي ممراته وفي ممرات المستشفى نعم
وضعهم سيء جدا الان وص صعب كون الوضع يمس
الان الجميع ويمس المجمع والنازحين نعم
انهم قلقون وخائفون وجميعا يحتمون في
ابنيه المستشفى ونحن الان على الهواء
مباشره
واطلاق النار متواصل في محيط مجمع ناصر
الطبي من المنطقه الجنوبيه والمنطقه
الشرقيه والمنطقه الشماليه جميع المناطق
الان معرضه ل اطلاق النار المتواصل
وهذا يحدث اصابات عشوائيه بين النازحين
وبين الماره في
الشوارع نفهم من ذلك ان الحركه في محيط
المستشفى او الابتعاد عن محيط المستشفى هو
من الامور الصعبه في هذه المرحله دكتور
ناهض نعم نعم جدا الان الامر صعب جدا
للتحرك حول المستشفى وحول محيط المستشفى
كون كثير من الطائرات المسيره تطلق النار
عشوائيه و يص لنا اصابات
كثيره اصابات عشوائيه في الصادر
والباطن في
الشوارع شكرا جزيلا لك من مجمع ناصر الطبي
في خان يونس الدكتور ناهض ابو طعيمه مدير
مستشفى الجراحه بالمجمع